[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this second chapter--
chapter number 1-- we
start talking about
quarks' and leptons'
interactions and fields.
And we start by a very
general discussion
of quantum fields and matter.
So you all know what we
mean by particles and forces
in the classical sense.
However, we need now to see
how they connect with quantum
fields, and how this helps us
to consider matter and forces
in a very similar way.
The modern view of the basic
way that particles come to exist
is in terms of
quantized fields, which
is an extension of the quantum
mechanics you love and know,
which you have done before,
where you quantize particles.
These fields have quantum
equations for their field
amplitudes which are
basically like the quantum
simple harmonic
oscillator, but there are
an infinite number of them--
one for every possible
frequency of wave in the field.
This means the amplitudes for
the wave for each frequency
are therefore quantized
in integer steps,
just like in a simple
harmonic oscillator.
This is what we
see as a particle.
The first excitation gives
one particle of a frequency.
The further excitation
of the amplitude
for the same frequency
corresponds to two particles.
Et cetera, et cetera.
So hence, the concept
of quantum field,
unlike normal quantum
mechanics, allows
an arbitrary and changeable
number of particles to exist.
This is necessary, as
you will see later,
such that we can create
and annihilate particles
in reactions and decays.
And the standard
wavefunctions correspond
to an equation of a
particular frequency,
amplitude when it exists
in the [INAUDIBLE]..
So now, just let's
consider a few cases here.
Imagine you have two particles--
two fermions, for example--
let's say two electrons.
And you consider
the wavefunction.
Quantum field
theory actually says
that there's only
one electron quantum
field for the whole universe,
and every electron which exists
is due to an excitation
of the field.
Hence, all electrons
are identical
in the quantum-mechanical
sense, as they all
arise from the same field.
The theory says, then, that
particular properties are
the resulting wave equations--
namely, their symmetry--
and the exchange
of these particles.
So the extra symmetry
depends on whether or not
the particle is a fermion,
which means it has spin 1/2
or 3/2 or 5/2, et cetera, or a
boson, which means that it has
spin 0, 1, or 2, and so on.
So for any identical
fermion and electron,
our quantum field theory
says that their wavefunction
must obey the property
of antisymmetry.
This means that when we
write an overall wavefunction
and we replace the particles,
we pick up a minus sign.
This property is not
just for electrons,
but for all fermions--
that's all matter particle,
as we saw last week.
So it also holds for
composite particles.
A composite spin-1/2 particle
is subject to the same
antisymmetry.
This property of exchange
antisymmetry leads
to a well-known principle--
namely, the Pauli principle,
which means that you cannot
have two electrons of the same
energy state or the same state,
because when you would actually
swap them, you find
that they are identical,
which is a stark contrast to
the actual description of this
wavefunction.
So this doesn't really work.
And therefore, two
electrons, or two fermions,
cannot be in the same state.
[INAUDIBLE] very general.
Constructing a wavefunction or
a total wave equation for two
fermions is not that hard.
We can simply do this
by this construction.
An important additional
statement or note to take here
is that an antiparticle
such as a positron
is not identical to a particle,
such as to the electron, again.
If you move on to bosons,
boson exchange is symmetric,
meaning that if you
[? request ?] two photons,
you find the identical
wavefunction.
And then constructing a
two-boson total wavefunction,
you do this by adding those
two functions together.
This is, by
definition, symmetric.
Let's look now forward
to exchange particles.
Again, you have a very good
idea of the classical picture
of how forces are transmitted.
So the modern picture of how a
force acts under quantization
is by emission and by
absorption of a particle.
That is shown in
this diagram here,
where let's say you have an
electron and a second electron.
They see each other.
And they see each other by
emitting and absorbing photons.
And you see this here.
So this electron comes along,
maybe emitting a photon.
This electron [? readmits ?] it.
And by this exchange of
emission and absorption
of photon, those two
particles, the [INAUDIBLE]
electrons to each other.
So this you can think about
like two ships shooting cannons,
if you want.
But you also have to consider
that there is not just
repelling forces, but
also attracting forces.
We could have replaced the
electron with a positron,
and the negative and
the positive charge
would interact with each other.
This is it for this short--
it's basically an intro
into the intro of the intro.
I hope you enjoy this.
All of those concept
we go into more detail.
This is really just
the starting point.
And then the next
lecture, you'll
see how we can
actually understand
aspects of this
diagram here, which
we call the Feynman diagram.